في غضون دقائق من إطلاق النار على
مركز كردي ، كان لدى الشرطة مشتبه به
محتجز في الحجز ، وصف أحد الشهود المشهد
الذي اعتقلوا فيه رجلاً عجوزاً
مسن طويل القامة وأن هناك ثلاثة
جرحى في الغرفة التي واصل الرجل
إطلاق النار عليها لكنه لم يستطع.  أطلق النار
بعد الآن لأنه لم يكن هناك المزيد من
الرصاص في مجلته عندما
وصل وزير الداخلية الفرنسي ، بدا
واثقًا من دافع مطلق النار ،
فليس من المؤكد أن القاتل الذي
أراد اغتيال هؤلاء الناس
وليس هناك شك في أنه يريد
اغتيال الناس هنا في  كانت باريس
تستهدف الأكراد على وجه التحديد ، وكان من الواضح أنه كان
يستهدف الأجانب في
غضون ساعات من إطلاق النار على الحشود
المتجمعة في الحي المختلط
عرقياً والمتوتر أحياناً حيث
وقع صراخ قتلة بعضهم في
الحشد ألقوا أشياء على الشرطة وفي
النهاية على رجال الإطفاء الذين تم
استدعاؤهم لإخماد الحرائق
اطلقت الشرطة من قبل المتظاهرين وابلا من
الغاز المسيل للدموع لتفريقهم
ما نعرفه الان عن  الحكومة هي
أن الفرنسي البالغ من العمر 69 عامًا والذي كان
خارج السجن فقط قد خرج من السجن
قبل 11 يومًا فقط لأنه كان
محتجزًا بشكل وقائي بسبب جريمة مماثلة
قبل عام ، ولا تزال الشرطة
تحقق ولكن في الوقت الحالي
يعتقدون أن هذا أمر  جريمة عنصرية
ليست بالضرورة جريمة إرهابية ،
فهم يحققون في جريمة قتل
ومحاولة قتل. قال مسؤولون في
المركز الذي وقعت فيه الهجمات إن
القتلى كانوا من النشطاء وقالوا
إنه سيكون هناك وقفة احتجاجية لتذكير
الجميع بهروب الجالية الكردية.
تذكير لا حاجة له ​​في هذا
الحي
Jim bitterman CNN Paris